- But now I get to introduce the next
and this is really our last,
it's not the last activity of the weekend,
but it's the last major thought panel.
And the focus instead of being on us
and what co-education was like for us
is much more institutional
what was co-education,
what impact did it have,
what is it continuing to have
and to the extent we have
a future looking panel,
hopefully we will talk about
what does co-education mean
today and even going forward.
I have the opportunity
to introduce someone
who has been introduced at
least four times so far,
so I'm gonna keep my comments brief.
Peter Salovey is the
23rd president of Yale.
He has been president since 2013
and I won't repeat anything
more than to welcome him up
to introduce the panel moderator, thanks.
(audience applauding)
- Thank You Barbara,
good afternoon everyone.
I'm proud to be president 23,
I get enormous amounts of clothing
particularly athletic wear
with the number 23 on it as a result.
And that's Michael Jordan and Kobe Bryant,
so I tease Rick, I always
say well who was 22 anyway?
I can't think of any 22s.
It's a really an honor to be able to offer
some introductory remarks
for Why Co-education Matters.
At this point in the
50th anniversary weekend,
you have been a part of
many crucial discussions
about how co-education began at Yale,
and what it was like for
the first trailblazers
who transformed this university.
And this afternoon our
panelists will explore further
the meaning of this anniversary
by examining past present
and future of co-education.
I was thinking that it's hard
to imagine a Yale without women.
So the Yale College without women.
Last May, 659 of the 1,350
undergraduate degrees
awarded at commencement went to women.
This Fall of course we
welcomed just as many women
as men into the Yale
College class of 2023.
By the way all of those first
years were wearing shirts
that said 23 on it and I
thought, isn't this nice?
They're greeting their president,
of course it had nothing to do with me.
Further today, today, right now, today,
seven of the 15 Dean's of the
undergraduate professional
and graduate schools are
women but in February,
as I mentioned to some of you yesterday,
that number goes to eight, more than half,
with the addition of dr. Nancy Brown,
the new Dean of the
Yale School of Medicine.
The senior fellow of the Yale Corporation
who is on this panel is a woman
but so was the previous senior fellow
and so was the senior fellow before her.
Don't let the word fellow fool you.
(audience applauding)
Co-education has increased
the representation of women
in every kind of role
at Yale in universities
around the world, in government agencies,
businesses and numerous
other sectors as well.
The women who led co-education,
who led the efforts in the 1960s and 70s
set the stage for our efforts today
to increase representation of women
in faculty positions
and in leadership roles
across all sectors.
So these trailblazers are
the ones who taught us,
you are the ones who taught us how to have
deeper discussions about
inclusion, about diversity,
about belonging for all individuals,
for people of every gender and every way
of understanding themselves.
As we celebrate co-education,
we look to a future
that's built on your work, your triumphs,
your experiences, your
wisdom of what provide
a foundation for students on campus today
and they helped shape Yale and
the world in the years ahead.
So I have to thank you
for the contributions
that you have all made that
have improved higher education
in scholarship and research
especially here at Yale
but at institutions around this country
indeed around the globe.
And I wanna thank you, those of you
who have remained interested in continuing
to further higher education
especially the promise
that the co-education of Yale
College presents to all of us.
So it is a pleasure for me
to introduce the moderator
of this afternoon's panel, Karen Lawrence,
from the class of 1971.
(all applauding)
- Karen currently serves as the president
of the Huntington Library Art Museum
and Botanical Gardens in
San Marino California.
Before that, she was the
president for a decade
of Sarah Lawrence College.
She's a renowned educator,
scholar, a leader.
She typifies the qualities
that Yale aspires
to inculcate among our students.
So she will tell you about
the rest of the panel,
but join me in welcoming
her and our colleagues
here this afternoon, thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank You president Salovey
and it's a real pleasure...
Can you hear me?
Okay, I think we've got the
mics solved, so that's good.
It's a pleasure to be here
and to introduce our esteemed panelists.
I do wanna say as a graduate of 1971
that it's been a pleasure
to relieve the moments
all together of our Fishbowl existence
as it was called in the survey.
And also, and the previous panel
was fabulous in doing that.
And also to place it in
the cultural contexts
in which its embedded.
And Sam Chauncey's discussion last night,
the fireside chat and
also the panel yesterday
on Yale society in the 60s,
I think really provided
that very important context.
I wanna say one personal thing about
that I think for most of us who were here,
co-education is embedded in that context.
And for me it's almost
impossible to think about it
and my education without thinking
about the political education and May Day.
And so I just wanna share
one very quick vignette,
I was in Davenport taking
a Davenport college seminar
with Anna Freud, one
of the 15 lucky people
students in Davenport who
could take the psychopathology
of childhood with Anna
Freud and Silas Mann.
And it was within ambivalence
that I faced that moment
when everybody made the decision
and she was going to leave.
But I was reminded at lunch
by one of my roommates
that the day before May Day and I stayed
and was involved in that with other folks.
And the day before May
Day, Anna Freud came
and spoke to the Davenport students
about her experience in
the Blitz in World War II.
And we gave her a Yale sweatshirt,
and my most vivid memory
is of Anna Freud putting on
a big sweatshirt with a Y over her dress
and totally unselfconsciously
and smiling at everyone
and then she left,
and she left the Yale
campus understandably
leaving at that moment.
But for me, those memories
and for many of us
I think are very embedded in that context.
So today we are gonna
look back a little bit
but really concentrate
as president Salovey said
on the present and what's
the unfinished business
of co-education both at Yale and elsewhere
and what have we learned about it.
You have the bios of
our impressive panelists
in your programs.
They are seasoned administrators,
I don't know that I'm gonna ask you
for the administrators
point of view but I'm sure--
- Fascinating, though it would be.
(audience laughing)
- Fascinating that would be, he says.
But everything that you've been and done
will be part of what you
know and your response.
I'm gonna just focus on their
multiple connections to Yale
and experiences of almost
different Yale's that they've had.
So Cathy or Catharine Bond Hill
is the former president of Vassar
and currently managing
director of Ithaka S+R Research
and Consulting Initiatives
to broaden access
to higher education.
She received her Ph.D. in
economics from Yale in 1985
at a time when I'm betting
you were one of the few women
at least, one of two
women in your classes.
She has the vantage point of now serving
on the board of Yale and U.S.
and is successor and senior
trustee of the Yale Corporation
and is professor emeritus of,
president emeritus of Vassar.
Kim Golf Crews experienced
Yale as an undergraduate
about 10 years after we did.
She graduated in '83 and
went to Yale Law School
and graduated from the Law School in '86.
She previously served as
assistant dean in the college
and director of the
Afro-American Cultural Center.
And now her vantage point
is as vice president
for student life at Yale and secretary
of the Yale Corporation.
Marvin Chun serves as Dean of Yale College
and is the Richard M. Colgate
Professor of Psychology
with appointments in cognitive science
in the Yale School of Medicine
Department of neuroscience.
He's also served as head
of Berkeley College.
I think Dick Brodhead
president emeritus of Duke
wins the award for the most
varied relation to Yale
on this panel at least.
He graduated from an all-male Yale in 1968
and was a graduate student
and a teaching assistant
and then a faculty member
all while we were going
through our education and served long
and very successfully
as Dean of Yale College
and has the most comprehensive
experience, I think,
of different Yale's.
So let me, I do wanna look back
and I do wanna talk about
briefly, that transition.
And bringing to bear
your other experiences
but certainly the transitional experiences
for you at that moment.
- Well, I've been thinking
about this and let me say,
you know listening to me
is to me always fascinating
but being here this
morning and hearing people
tell all those particular personal stories
of where different people
found their friends,
where different people
found their opportunities
in their futures that was just so fun.
So I'll just whirlwind my two cents.
I came to Yale in 1964,
well maybe I'll start this way.
I was president of Duke for 13
years and while I was there,
we spent a year and a half celebrating
a deeply significant 50th anniversary,
the 50th anniversary of the admission
of the first African
American students to do.
Now you can say, how is that possible?
But it was a segregated
state let's remember
and although I went to
Yale at the same time,
Yale was not segregated but
there were 10 black students
in a class of 1,000 when I was there.
So it was something, it was something.
Now the interesting thing
is when say when Duke
was integrated for
college students in 1963,
this was after there had already been 10
or maybe even 15 years
of very active agitation
about the issues of racial exclusion
not only on the Duke campus
but across the South in Durham,
itself had been a center of this agitation
going back to the early 1950s.
Now I put that in my
mind and I compared it
to what it was like to raise the subject
of the admission of women
to Yale in 1965, '6 '7.
And here's why I got
to tell you, you know,
I was a smart person, my
classmates were smart people
but you know I just will admit it to you,
when I came here I did not come here
because it was an all-male
school or in hopes
that it would soon be co-educated.
You know, my classmates
understood that Yale was all-male,
it had already been for
200 and what, do the math,
263 years by that point
so was every other school
we would have gone to
if we hadn't gone here.
And so if you asked a
male student at that time,
why does Yale not have women?
The answer would have been I think just,
I'll just put it more positively,
why does Yale admit only man?
I think the answer would
have been, because it does,
because that's just the way it is.
None of us like thought
much more deeply about that.
If you had said to any
member of my class that Yale
admitted only man because it had a mission
to produce 1,000 male leaders,
we all regarded that phrase
with great scorn and dripping sarcasm
whenever we mentioned it.
So here was a place
that was all male, why?
Because it just was.
That was true in my freshman year,
I do not remember a
discussion of the subject
in my freshman year, I
don't remember a discussion
in my sophomore year, I
can remember the beginning
of discussions in my junior year.
And then it falls in
the category of things
that went from being
unthinkable to mandatory
without ever passing through
the phase of reflection.
All of a sudden me and
everybody I knew understood
that it was now totally
wrong for this place
to be exclusive of women and
then it had to admit women
as quickly as possible.
It was in my senior year the
co-education week took place,
obviously for later taught my
wife Constitutional Law is,
you know, I knew him, we
all participated in it.
And people in my village
believe that the reason
Yale co-education is because
it was about to be co educated
by its students if it did not make
the administrative concession do that.
So there it is, it went from unthinkable
to has to happen and sure enough
it happened very quickly thereafter.
But so now I just, you
know, by now you've heard
the reasons why Yale co-educated.
Nancy Malkiel gave a
very thought-provoking
and I believe historically accurate
strategic account of the
administration's logic.
And I could give and you
could give an account
based on morality and social justice
or even the social policy of
why Yale needed to co-educate.
But I'm just gonna give you the reasons
why it was important to a young man
who was a student at that time.
And there'd be twofold,
one if you went here,
you had a lot of great male friends
but friendship with women
was an unknown phenomenon.
Really pretty much that's
true, if you think about it.
I had also gone to an
all-male school for four years
before I came here, you're
used to schools being all-male
and then occasionally
something happened in college
that never happened in boarding school
which is buses would arrive
and women would arrive
and they would go up the
stairs and then you go
and ask them to dance and whatever you can
possibly accomplish beyond that point.
And then it was all over.
And as I say, I mean I'd have to say,
no one regarded this
I was fun at the time,
it was very distasteful.
There was something, you know,
I don't wanna use the word
but it's not too strong of a word,
there was something debasing.
Not only for the victims of
it but for oneself as well.
And I did not regard road trips,
I mean you know Vassar meant road trips,
and I did not regard road trips
as that much more fun either.
It was just the nature, you know,
did you ever read The Scarlet Letter,
remember what Hester Prynne
wants to do at the end?
She wants a utopian colony
where someone will understand
how to put the relations of men and women
on a surer ground of mutual happiness.
That's what Yale needed at that point.
The relations of men and
women were on a ground
of total abnormality, total unnaturalness.
And so it seems to me, I'd have to say
in my own personal life, reaching a state
where women could be just your friends,
where they could know you just as you
and you could know them just as them,
that was actually something
it took co-education
to produce at this University.
By chance, I believe I attended
the first fully co-educated
class in year college.
When I was a senior, I had to take Latin
because I was going to
go to graduate school
and you had to have passed
tests in many languages.
So I took first year Latin as a senior
but the class was filled with women.
In the graduate school, they're to pass
their language requirements
who were graduate students
in music and French,
Nancy Vicker's friends
were in this class.
And I thought all of a
sudden you're at a class
where half or more of the
students were women and you know,
we just became friends
and that was the beginning
of a whole new chapter of
maturity in my education.
So it seems to me in some sense,
it was about humanizing
life for co-education.
But then I discovered a second reason
that I still wouldn't have
been aware of in 1968.
You've heard the strange fact,
I entered graduate school
in the Fall of '68, my
classmates were at least
half women there and I
immediately had many women friends
including one who I married.
That Fall, it was announced
that Yale would admit women,
the following Fall women were admitted
and the following Fall,
I drew my first to teaching assignment.
Now please keep in mind, I am a person
who had only ever wanted
to do one thing on earth,
and that's probably still true,
which was to be a college teacher
but I never done it, you know.
And so all of a sudden, in
Alvin Kern and Shakespeare class
I had to lead a discussion
section of my first class.
But by that point the class already had
a significant number of women,
Lydia Wegman is here somewhere.
Where are you?
There you are, you were in my class.
Is there anybody else
who was in that class?
Where are the rest of you?
Yeah, you, who are you?
Yell me your name.
(background noise drowns other sounds)
I might have been, all right.
So this room contains my actual
and my potential students, okay.
But anyway, but here's the funny thing,
so when I started teaching of course,
you know this was a discussion section,
it was not a lecture, so
you went in and tried to ask
interesting and provocative questions
and right away you found
this is a piece of cake
because people would
just raise their hands
and plunge in and begin to discuss
all these interesting things.
But I'd have to say, the
discussions in that class
were different than they had been
when I had been an undergraduate
two short years before in all-male Yale.
I never was a student in co-educated Yale
and I never was a teacher
in an non co-educated Yale.
But right away in that
class you saw, you know,
women light class discussion,
they raised their hands,
they plunged right into it.
The students in my class
nothing reminded me of them
so much as hearing the people
on the panel this morning.
All that vitality, all
that articulateness,
all that confident, the
confidence, I just desire
to go in and get at it.
And you know it had the funny thing
which is it actually made
men behave differently
in class discussion because
male Yale up 'til 1968
was under the tyranny of
very oppressive stereotypes
for men within the college,
one of which is, it's
good to be intelligent
but it's not good to
care too much about it.
It's good to be intelligent but
not good to be intellectual.
And so there was a kind of
pose of what shall we call it,
relaxation, gentlemanly leisure.
I could if I would, you
know what I'm talking about
and actually the interesting
thing is once the class started
and men were occupying the
pose of gentlemanly leisure
and women were making all
the interesting points,
that wasn't gonna last very long.
And soon the men discovered
that they not only wanted
to do this too but could do it too.
And I'd have to say,
I'm not sure this point
has been made as deeply
as I would make it,
the deepest change that
co-education made for Yale
is that it made it an academically vibrant
and vital place for its undergraduate.
(audience applauding)
I would never, let me say what,
don't show me the yellow card yet,
I've got one more thing
to say, no yellow card.
Just one more thing.
And in those classes the whole point
is all of a sudden you
had women in the classes,
the point has been made many times,
no one was ever there to
be called on or to speak
the woman's point of view.
It would never have occurred to me
to ask a student to say that.
Nevertheless, if you have
excluded half of humanity
from your class for this point,
you may be sure there's
gonna be points of view
now present that used to be absent.
And so it was not only the vibrancy
but also the fullness of consideration
that was changed there.
And then I remember
something that happened
in my second year and I'm
trying to make eye contact
with Margaret Hohman (mumbles),
you know feminism came
together with co-education
into the life of male students at Yale.
And an interesting thing is
I couldn't remember teaching,
did any of you ever take English 25,
Chaucer, Spenser, Milton, Pope.
Remember there's a poem by
Pope that we all used to teach
called Epistle To A Lady
on the character of women.
Remember its first line,
"Nothing so true as
what you once let fall,
most women have no character at all."
(audience laughing)
And then it goes on and it's
a very witty brilliant poem.
And at the end of the
class, I remember a student,
I'll tell you her name
though I do not know her
since she graduated, Judith
Fabricant was her name,
very smart, she raised her hand and said,
"Nevertheless, what do
you think of somebody
who would say nothing so true
was what you once left fall,
most women have no character at all?"
And you know, just all of
a sudden I'd have to say,
at that moment you saw the
scales fell from your eyes
and you realized the implicit selectivity,
the implicit limitations of the things
that had been taken for granted as true
by everybody up to that point.
That was the biggest maybe later changes
but this is the very end, the end.
- We'll begin tomorrow of the curriculum
and how it changed with women.
But I do wanna...
Yeah.
(audience applauding)
In a couple of the panels,
we were talking about when Yale changed.
And I do wanna ask actually whether
one of the things that emerged
of the cultural context
was that there were more public school men
who came to Yale leading
up to co-education
who might not have found it as bizarre
to have women in the classroom.
And so I just kind of
wanna ask about that point
that there were antecedent conditions--
- Oh clearly, they were.
Clearly, they were.
- Or faculty who began
to be hired from Midwest schools where--
- Sure, and you can go read the history,
the thing is in the class
of '67 was the first class
that had a majority of
public school matriculants.
There had been as many as
65% from private schools,
from private boarding schools.
And I think at one point I heard,
more than 50% of Yale students
used to come from the same eight schools.
I went to end over, there were 45 people
from my high school class
in my freshman class
when I came here.
Guess what, the next year
there were 22 from that school
and it never reached
such a high number again.
And surely that change helped a bit.
It's all part of a larger change.
- Right.
- I'm just describing my
personal experience of it.
- All right, thank you.
When we talk about co-education,
I think Sam Chauncey was quoted
in the recent alumni magazine as saying,
"People keep talking about co-education
as if this was some magical thing
that never happened before anywhere else."
And we're here because
it was crucial to us
to the institution that is
what we're talking about.
It is true that in 1955,
75% of all colleges
and universities enrolled both
male and female undergraduates.
And that often comparisons are made
and there's wonderful
literature on comparisons
between elite men's schools.
And sometimes in the
literature comparisons
about the benefits of
co-education for women
versus single sex education.
So these are parts of the discussion.
I wanna turn to Cathy
who was the president
of a college that went
co-ed the other way around
and admitted men as a minority
to a majority female campus.
And I share that with
you as Sarah Lawrence,
Vassar received Yale's
proposal as did Sarah Lawrence,
I mean rejected Gail's proposal
as Sarah Lawrence rejected Princeton's.
Can you talk a little bit
about that process and outcome.
- Sure, so it's been wonderful to be here
and it was so interesting
to hear people this morning.
My own personal experience
is actually more similar to yours.
I was in the second class of
all women at Williams College
which moved to co-education
a little bit more slowly
than Yale but not by much
of some my entering class
was the fall of '72
and I graduated in '76.
So very, a lot of very common experiences.
And then I went back to Williams
to teach and was Provost
and then went to the Vassar position.
When I went from Williams to Vassar,
of course I dug into
the archives to find out
about this period of time
when both Williams went co-ed
and Yale went co-ed and Vassar went co-ed.
And it was really fun to learn
a little bit about the history.
It had really started in the early 60s
and in the archive so you
could see the presidents
starting to really worry
about what was gonna happen
as it was clear the
demographics were changing
and what students were interested
in was changing as well.
I couldn't get to town in time
to hear Nancy's talk yesterday
but we actually talked quite a lot
when she was working on her book
because she was trying to
dig into the Vassar data
on what happened to the student body
during this period of time.
So anyway I learned a lot
about Vassar going co-ed
and just some interesting
stories, I think.
Very early on when I was at Vassar,
I was meeting with the class of '69
and they were the last
all-female class at Vassar
about which they were quite proud.
But it was so interesting the
first time I met with them
because they were very divided
on what right path was for Vassar.
Some of them were just completely appalled
by the notion that that Vassar
would have merged with Yale,
some of them were quite appalled
that it was gonna go co-ed
and some of them just were really sad
that they didn't get a
chance to have a Yale degree.
So it was this very mixed
history of that class.
So Vassar goes co-ed, it goes co-ed
for many of the same
reasons that Williams did
which was that it was clear
and I think Nancy's book
makes this point that
the world had changed
and it was going to be
very hard to survive
in an isolated community as
a single sex institution.
What it did at Vassar was
changed the pool of students
who were applying to go there.
Before for many of you, I
think many of you actually
started at one of the
women's, the Seven Sisters
and then transferred, you
didn't have the option
of going to Princeton or
Yale or Williams or Amherst.
Once those opportunities arose you made
a more decided decision about
what kind of an institution
you wanted to go to.
And I would say that
what happened at Vassar
was that the applicant
pool changed from women
who would have applied
to Princeton or Yale
or Williams or Amherst
if it were an opportunity
to women who wanted to go
to an elite private nonprofit institution
with wonderful faculty,
but that had a history
of being a woman's college.
And wanted to be at an institution
that was less masculine in a way.
So the pool changed to women
who were more self-selecting
to go to Vassar.
The male students that were coming,
I would say were similar in the same way.
They were making a decision
that they wanted to go
to an institution that
was not as masculine
as some other institutions
now that this opportunity was available.
And they fell into a variety
of I think different camps.
We had a longtime admissions director
who was really a wonderful person
who was there for quite a long time.
He's passed away, so I feel
okay telling a story about him
but he talked about that the
applicant pool of young men
often being young men who
you know had been bullied
in high school by other men
or young boys at that point
and wanted in an environment
that was not like that.
And so I think we ended up
with a much more selective
applicant pool both on the
on the part of men and women
who wanted the kind of
environment that a college
that had had 150 years of educating women
was gonna be a comfortable environment.
- Which suggests that
there's something in the DNA
that carries on from the the history
of having been in all women's college
and that might also suggest that the same
thing happens in a college that
goes co-ed and admits women.
I think we've been
talking about going co-ed
as if it's an arrival or a destination
but in fact it's a process.
So I'd like to turn to Kim
and Marvin to ask about,
is that DNA still at Yale
in some sort of palpable way
in terms of the unfinished
business of co-education
or is there a sense of
that for students today?
- You wanna start.
- Good afternoon, thank
you all for coming.
I really enjoyed the
sessions yesterday and today
especially the one this morning.
It's very inspiring for
me and my role as Dean
to hear about our histories
and to see, you know,
your adventurous and your resilient selves
really forging a path for
Yale to be what it is today
which I do think is a
really outstanding place
for educating all our students.
I'm looking at my name card over here
and I look very undereducated.
Everyone else has all
these fancy credentials
but I wanted to point that out
because there is one
credential that's missing here
which is that I'm a parent.
My daughter is a junior
here and so I get to see
what an incredible place
Yale is through her eyes.
(audience applauding)
And you know for me the
value of co-education
really just rests on the
fact that if our students,
if our faculty, if we as a community,
if our mission is to serve the world,
then we really need to
look like the world.
And it kind of really
everything really boils down
to that very simple fact.
And with regards to unfinished work,
I think of course we've
made amazing progress
and Yale now is very very
different from the Yale
I've been hearing about
over the past two days.
But there's still work
to do, I think one area
is that we do need more
diversity in our faculty, right,
it came up in discussion yesterday
that 32% of our latter
faculty in the Faculty of Arts
and Sciences are women
which is great progress,
it's as high as it's
ever been but of course
it's still quite distant from 50%.
But there's a aspect of those
data that's very promising
and Dean Tamar Gendler here
can say more about it perhaps.
But a very promising aspect of those data
is that it's 32% because
that's the entire faculty,
you know ranging from
recently PhD to people
who've been here for 30 40 years.
If you just look at the
cohort of new faculty
who arrived here in the past 10 years,
45% of those of the new faculty are women.
So I think the trends
are looking very good,
thanks to the good
efforts of our president
and Dean Gendler.
And I think this is very
important for our student body
which of course has parity
to have a faculty that looks,
that represents what
the students are like.
In terms of another challenge
for undergraduate students,
47% of our STEM students are women.
So that's, you know there's (mumbles).
(audience applauding)
But you may know that still
women representation in STEM
is low around the country
and this is a number
that we have to keep stay focused on.
There are still some fields
where the proportion of women
are lower than 47% and that's been,
that's an important
priority for me to raise
in my role as dean.
So I think I'll pause there.
- So first of all, I did
graduate 10 years after you
and so it's actually
wonderful to be able to see
the shoulders that I'm
standing on in person.
So it's been really
wonderful to hear your voices
and to spend all the day with you to hear
some more about your stories.
I also have the privilege
of being secretary
and also vice president
for student life here
and that means that I'm very focused
on the student experience
largely outside of the classroom,
so I like to say that I
focus on where students eat,
sleep, play, pray and pay.
(panel laughing)
Anything outside the classroom is fine
and I think about that for all students,
not just the college but
all students on campus.
But having been a member of the college
both in the dean's office
and also I worked for Dick actually,
and also an undergrad I do have
a special place in my heart
for the undergraduates that I work with
and the leadership that I work with.
I think that what we would say to you
in terms of, and now I'm
channeling a lot of their voices,
is that yes, co-education has worked
in terms of the diversity,
in terms of the number
but we are all focused
on issues of equity,
inclusion and belonging.
And what that means is that we are focused
on making sure that all of our students
have equal opportunity here in ways
that focus on the legal
definition of legal equity
but also that they feel included,
that they always feel as
if they have opportunities
that are meaningful for
them and that they belong
which means they can be
their authentic self.
And so a lot of our student leaders,
particularly women leaders are focused
on those aspects of what
it means to be at Yale
and feel that although
we have made progress
that's some of the areas that
we really need to focus on.
I think of Title Nine as
being one of the issues
that many of our students,
and we have to name that
because that is something very much
in our students minds right now
in terms of the campus
climate which has improved
and which we are all stealing
still working on including.
I think of very much
this group of young women
being multi hyphenates and intersectional,
that they are very much
focused on gender and,
'cause they always think of themselves
as being multiple and
holistic in their view.
And so what does that mean?
In fact just this week they talked to me,
that women leaders talk
to me about making sure
they could see themselves
in a variety of ways
and not just as women.
So we can have more
conversation about that
but I think the demographic piece
we have done well at Yale College
but I think it's the inclusion
of more the belonging piece
that we are now all focused
on as student leaders
and the rest of us in terms of making this
the best experience for these young women
we have here.
- Great, there are two
directions I'd love to go
in relation to what you both have said.
One is actually to follow
up on your experience
Marvin as a parent and
the sense of the climate
with the daughter here.
And I've been talking to people
and that's something we
haven't really talked about
is the experience of the
children of our class
and whether that's, you
know, how they experience.
And now I guess I am asking
you to speak for your daughter
and I was asking people not
to speak for someone else.
But I'm interested in that
and maybe from the audience,
if there's any comment
about the kind of climate
or in the DNA of a school, its history
or have your daughters or
sons felt a very different,
obviously a very different environment.
I mean there's no question
but anybody wanna...
Yeah, Susan.
- I'm Susan Waisbren from class of '71.
I have two daughters who were
in graduate programs here
in the Art History program
and then a resident
at the medical school.
And what struck me is
something that I struggled with
when I was here which was
I wanted the opportunities
of being a man but I didn't
wanna live my life as a man
in terms of my career.
And watching my daughters now
who are young mothers as well,
they're being crushed by the
amount of responsibilities
that they have.
And I say to them, now
that you're 50% doctors,
now that you're, you know,
50% almost professors,
you need to stand up for
how can a woman be a mother
and also her career and not
have four overnights a week
(mumbles).
(audience applauding)
- So the advantages and
some of the tribulations
that come from those opportunities.
I don't know Marvin if you
wanna say anything else
about the next generation (mumbles).
- So over 50 years and in fact
even in the past 10 years,
we continue to evolve and try to make this
a more inclusive climate.
One area that seems now very natural
but definitely it did
not exist 10 years ago
is that our housing is gender-neutral now.
And so the bathrooms have
always been gender neutral,
I mean or unshared but the housing,
the configurations themselves
have gone gender-neutral
over the past 10 years recently extended
to first-year students as well.
So we continue to evolve in that sense.
I'm gonna choose not to
represent my daughter
because she doesn't like that
but in general speaking again
with my administrative hat,
I think progress continues to be made.
Challenges in areas where
we still need to work on,
they're still gendered,
they're still exist
gendered social spaces.
On the bright side organizations,
groups like that where improves
have gone co-ed last year
as I'm sure many of you are aware
but there are still many singing groups
that are single sex.
There are still Greek
organizations that are single sex.
So these are areas that we
have to continue to attend to.
- And I would say I think
going to your specific story
is what you see a lot in
this particular generation
of young women in the
college is conversations
about balance and wellness.
So as a generation, they
have really been focusing
on how best to manage their
time and their energy.
They are also talking about the concept
of effortless perfection
and trying to sort of kill
that dragon at the same time.
So we spent a lot of
time developing programs
that address that issue.
In fact Laurie Santos had a
course a couple of years ago
called The Psychology of The Good Life
but we have built The Good Life Center
in so many colleges and we
have a chance to look at it
which basically offers
classes that help you
make a decision about how
you're gonna manage your time
and your energy but also
how do you manage your life
and how do you think things through.
So there's ways in which this generation
is just much more focused
on making sure certainly,
I'm talking about the college now
and your students are a
little bit older than them.
But the college, the young
women are much more focused
on trying to make sure
they have a balanced life.
- And it also raises the
question of professions.
- Yes.
- And coming, being at
Yale as a graduate student,
I mentioned, so you were one
of two Cathy in economics.
But how do we need to see our discussion
of undergraduate
co-education within a lens
that includes professions that women enter
and the different times,
the different time periods
where various fields admitted women
had more women, what about (mumbles)--
- I'm hoping will continue to
see things evolve over time
and I think as we have more
women faculty coming up
through the ranks as we
have more women lawyers,
more women doctors that that
they will start thinking
about the workplace and
making sure that it's a place
that's comfortable for
not just women but men
as they try to have lives
outside of their professions.
I'm seeing amongst the
(mumbles) three kids
who are all in a not quite there yet
but thinking about these
issues both two boys and a girl
and they care about
balance, all of them do.
And so I think this
generation is gonna bring
those values into the workplace
and that's what we need them to do
to make it more reasonable
for both men and women
to lead lives that work as well.
- Kim I wanna follow up on what you said
about gender fluidity and a whole,
I mean again the word,
the term co-education
presupposes binary or mostly presupposes
that and as you pointed out
on college campus today,
there's a very different
discussion vocabulary
and climate around sexual
identification gender,
identification, how does
that, how do we need to think
about that in relation to the
discussion about co-education?
- Well, we think about
it certainly in terms
of as Marvin mentioned,
gender-neutral bathrooms
and you saw the all gender
bathrooms right down the hall.
And how do you negotiate that
when you have multiple generations?
Some of us actually still
want men and women's bathroom,
so how do you manage that with students
who are looking for something different.
But we also have, we're looking at things,
very basic things like,
you know, how do we account
for someone's gender changing gender
or their gender identity on class list
because they're generated very much
by you know our database
and how do we help faculty
understand who is in front of them,
how do we help faculty
understand the person
whose name that might be legally Michael
might be Michelle at some point.
So we've got systems
in place we've designed
to make sure that an accurate identity
is in front of the faculty members.
And we are actually
doing a lot of training
with faculty and staff and students
about transgender students
which is a very big component
of the population of
student issues on campus
on across the country.
So we're always thinking about gender
broader than just male-female.
Even in my reports that
I get from my staff
about you know who's in the room
and they give me a list
of students I might meet.
Well, they'll say something like,
"Well, we have four people
presenting as male."
So even our language has shifted
in terms of how we address the issue
but it certainly our
policies, our programs,
even though some of our billings
are sort of addressing that.
So we've got to be much broader
in terms of how we think
about these issues.
- Let me throw that open
to anyone else on the panel
to talk about intersectionalities
and fluidity of gender
and just the way of thinking about
who comes to the college and inclusion
and how they feel included.
- Anybody else?
- Intersectionality and
inclusion are inter-acting
and overlapping but by no
means identical issues.
It seems to me Cathy is one
of the most famous people
in the country associated with the idea
of promoting inclusion.
And I'd have to say
anybody who'd say nowadays,
you know, was co-education
over, was it accomplished
when women took up their
places as students?
Yes and no, right.
It was and it wasn't.
It was because they were here,
it wasn't because Yale needed to be remade
to become the place
they would be fully able
to live up to their highest potential in.
But I think anybody who
lived here at the time
realizes that the deepest
thing co-education did to Yale
is to induce the habit every so often
of looking at the university
and asking yourself,
I know it's great but is it really,
does this place really serve the mission
it pushed forward in the world?
And at a certain point, Yale
couldn't answer that question
when it excluded women.
And so women were included,
certainly it happened
the same with the question
of race in a significant way
also in the late 60s and early 70s.
And you know now of course we
are all much more preoccupied
with socioeconomic
questions now that we know
the very high correlation
between family income level
from birth to going to
college preparation,
over preparation, grooming that people get
and how those correlate.
And so I think that's really,
I think as someone who was
but until very recently,
a university president, I would say,
that's been the new horizon,
the main new horizon
that co-education opened up for us.
And the thing is even when that is solved
to our satisfaction, I
hope after about five years
people will say, all right,
we've reached the stage
of self-satisfaction again,
now let's ask the question again,
is this place actually
open to all the people
it has a mission to serve?
- Yeah, I think just one
of the real challenges
on college campuses is getting students
to listen to each other
and as our communities
become significantly more diverse
just one of the real advantages
of being here for four years
is to learn from people that
have had different experiences.
And sometimes I think there's a tendency
to not let that happen
and to choose one identity
and feel like you need
to somehow defend it.
And I think certainly my time at Vassar
was reminding students to take advantage
of the amazing diversity of the campus
and not only speak up
but listen to their peers
about their experiences as well.
- All right, I wanna open
it up now for questions
for the remainder of our time.
So we have about 20 minutes for questions.
Yeah.
- Hello, I'm Susan Trina
Quay, 1971 Calhoun.
I wonder whether any
thoughts been given at Yale
in addressing co-education values
through modifications
of traditional pedagogy.
We know that co-ed and
all-male classrooms,
the dynamics are quite different
from all-female classrooms.
We also know that female instructors
are challenged much more
frequently both by both male
and female students that
are male instructors.
And finally we know that the
traditional pedagogical model
at Yale, the sage on the
stage, well usually a guy
in a tweed jacket, something like that,
maybe a woman who is following that model
maybe suits a kind of masculine culture
but may not bring out the strength
and a feminine culture
or something in between.
So my question, I think
going beyond the question
of how to retain the
best women instructors
to build a truly diverse faculty,
what is being done to
examine pedagogical models
that are popular at Yale?
I'll only say this, and this
may be too ancient history,
I don't know they remember
the old joke I heard
when I came to Yale, how
many Yale's does it take
to screw in a light bulb?
Want to screw it in and
one to kick out the stool
underneath him while he's trying to do it.
When I came to Yale, I was really stunned
at the level of brutal competition,
finding pages and books razored out
that have been left on reserve
in cross campus and so on
and that there were no rules
when it came to winning.
I've assumed that's moderated over time
but the kind of valorisation
of that kind of competition
and the valorisation of a
highly authoritative professor,
I think speaks to a kind of DNA at Yale
that may need some re-examination.
So what do you think?
- I wonder if I could pitch into this.
You've just described a Yale,
I've been here all that time, right,
until I was here for 40 years
for my first freshman day
until I left the faculty.
The Yale you describe of
the man knocking the stool
out from another it's not one I ever knew.
I never experienced that kind
that kind of competitiveness
at this place.
(audience applauding)
I think if women had come to a place
that had that culture it
would have been very different
and I bet even that would have
had a modifying force in it.
But don't forget as for the
model of pedagogy, you know,
let me just say, I was a
department chair, I was a Dean,
the greatest lecturers in my department
included both men and
women, the greatest seminar,
Susie Wofford, is in this room.
Your classmate who was
such a great one then,
Tamar Gendler, a great one
of more modern vintage.
But the great majority
of you have instruction
is done in small groups.
And where it does not, in
small groups never work
if it's all me me me on
the part of the faculty.
Finding a way to be gifted
at seminar instruction
is one of the really
powerful things universities
teach students 'cause it has to do,
how do you find an interesting question
and then how do you create the space
where different people can
hazard some portion of the answer
and learn from each other?
That's a great thing
universities teach people.
And it seems to me the small group culture
was strong from my earliest
days on the faculty
and I believe is probably
even stronger now.
- I also think there's a lot more emphasis
on helping faculty think about pedagogy
so that their classroom can be supportive
for everybody that's around the table.
That that was not something
that you've learned
in graduate school when I was here
but now it is something that institutions
are much more conscious of.
And I just wanna say there were 30 people
in the Econ PhD program
the year I came, two women,
it was incredibly supportive.
And I loved every minute of it.
So I also did not experience that.
And other PhD programs
had other reputations
and so part of the
reason for coming to Yale
was precisely because it did
not have that reputation.
- And I just have to
add and dump on there,
I think we're very fortunate
that our reputation
in higher education especially
amongst this generation
of students is that we
are a strong community,
we are a collaborative community,
we are supportive of each other.
So this competitive notion,
I think really lives in the past.
I also wanna add that
we've done, we do surveys,
not survey, sorry, we analyze
the effectiveness of teachers
and how students view their teachers
both for small classes and large classes.
And on average, our women faculty
actually received
numerically higher ratings
from other students and
than the male faculty do
if we break it down by gender.
The second thing I'll
say is that regarding
the kind of a big
authoritative large lectures,
this is course by Professor Laurie Santos
is the largest in Yale College history.
And so I think it's
because of her charisma
and the respect that
students have for who she is
that has led to its size.
Even this semester, the largest
class is taught by women,
my wife and even though she's
going against at the same time
a distinguished male professor,
Akhil Amar of Constitutional Law.
So I think I think the
culture is pretty good.
- And also just so you know
that right across the street
is the physical manifestation
of our commitment to pedagogy
which is the Poorvu Center
for Teaching and Learning
which does a lot of training of faculty
about new ways of teaching
and experiential learning
and how to deal with
people who are introverted.
So all kinds of ways of
making sure the class dynamics
are really rich because if they weren't,
we would probably wouldn't be getting
as many students as we are
but that is our commitment.
- Yeah, so there's been a
lot of change in the way
on multiple campuses how people
are trained in pedagogical,
you know and to think
about that and teaching,
but I have to say I think that Yale
has always been focused
on undergraduate teaching
in a very real authentic way.
As part of the university it's not a place
where the only thing that faculty cared
about when we were there
and now is research
and not how that enters into the classroom
and what happens among students.
So, yep, back there.
- (mumbles) my name is
Cate Moore, class of '73.
Did you hear that?
I have a question, not a speech,
and I'd like to direct the
question primarily to Kimberly
and to Marvin, is that right?
We have the rise of the cultural centers
but what mechanisms are we
actively using to promote
civil discourse among the
different cultural components
of the student body?
(audience applauding)
- That goes back to Cathy's
question as well, Kim.
- So one of the things
we've been focusing on
on the last year and a
half is what we call,
training students on how to
have difficult conversations
and this is one of the
things that actually came up
from the student body.
We have an advisory group of talking
about what are some of the issues
we should be dealing
with and this one things
that they all seem to say that
we need to be focusing on,
Marvin and I, and actually
mostly Marvin's gonna start
working with a group of
faculty members to come up
with some programming,
very specific programming
including classroom,
hopefully classroom work
to help students interact
differently with each other.
But the students themselves are actually
coming up with informal
ways of educating each other
about different issues.
We are actually promoting conversations
with different viewpoints
on the same platform
because typically what happens
mostly because of it's difficult to get
to pay for multiple speakers
on the same platform.
We're trying to make sure that students
have the money to be able to do that
so they tend invite one person at a time.
We would like to have three or four people
off the same topic coming
from different perspective.
So you'll see that a lot more.
So we're paying a lot
more attention to that.
So (mumbles) think you'll see more
in the next couple of
years particularly given
the social and the political climate,
we feel it's very important to double down
on those kind of skill sets for students.
And so with student leadership,
Marvin and I are trying
to work on that now.
Thank you for your question.
- Thank you and just to add a little,
you know, we're fortunate here at Yale
to have the most powerful
mechanism for promoting learning
from each other and civil
discourse which in my view
is the residential
colleges because we force--
(audience applauding)
Because we require
students to live together
and you know for at least two
years because we mix them up,
you know, you can't really choose to live
and spend all your time with
people who are like yourselves.
And because we put so much resources
into the dining-hall
community and you know,
after our evening a buttery community,
students are really always
find themselves in settings
where they can meet people who
are different from themselves
and hear their different perspectives.
And you know, and
sometimes it can be tense
but at least where people
are in conversation.
And so coupled with the
programs that Kim has described
that we're working hard to develop.
I think we are in a good
position to address this.
So it is a very high priority for us.
- Okay, woman right there.
- Pat Williams, class of
'71, I was in Pearson.
Drunken parties at Yale have gotten
a lot of publicity lately and--
- Which parties, sorry
could you say that again?
- Drunken--
(background noise drowns other sounds)
- Oh, drunken parties, okay.
- And I'm wondering what attention is paid
to that aspect of
substance abuse on campus?
- We do a lot of training for students
when they initially come
in about our policies
and we have a number of students on campus
who they're called a
Communication Consent Corners
to talk a little bit about
how the party effectively
and work with student
organizations to make sure
that they're doing
something appropriately,
effectively meaning safely.
Sometimes what we find
out is that when parties
are at campus, they're actually
well done and they're safe
but when students go off campus,
that's where we have more problems.
So we're spending a lot
more time with fraternities
and sororities, mostly fraternities,
to have conversation with them
about what our expectation
are and monitoring them
in very different ways
but we're also spending
a lot of time frankly with
the students themselves
to make sure they're
looking out for each other
and they understand how to how to party
a little bit more safely.
So we haven't had as
many issues on campus.
In fact, one of the innovations
that Marvin did this year
was to have a huge
party the first weekend,
the first weekend that the
first year's class came on,
so all of campus, was it
off, was across campus,
was taken over--
- Old campus.
- Old campus, old campus
was taken over for something
we call the Bulldog
bash which is something
we've done for two years
running which is a party
that we throw where the
Schwarzman Center at Marvin's team
throws which has five acts
going from 9:30 to 2 p.m.,
- Am.
- Through 2 a.m.,
if feels like 2 p.m for those
that were actually there.
And it does have a beer
garden where you have to,
older students can go and
including graduate students,
lots of food and basically
there's so much fun
that nobody actually
ever goes away from that.
So they have a experience
of having a really good
that first party being really really fun,
meeting people in a safe environment
and having better sets of ideas
about how to party more
safely other places.
So we're trying to have again programming,
good modeling and a lot of
conversations with students
that we think might be
problematic early on.
- I was a college head for nine years
and I've run many events
with alcohol, beer and wine
for my senior students and
I've not had a single student
misbehave or get sick at any
of the events that I hosted.
And what this told me was
that if we can throw a party
that serves alcohol and treat
the students like adults,
the young adults that
they are then they respond
and act responsibly as well.
The big problem is that
the drinking age of 21
forces our students to
have these underground,
under supervised parties which
are happening off-campus.
And that has just been
a real big challenge
to address and regulate.
That said, just on the
notion of Bulldog bash party,
we're gonna do a miniature version of that
for you all tonight on
Old Campus at 9:00 p.m.
and to help you model--
- Make sure to bring your ID.
- Yeah, the party will be (mumbles),
so please a pregame before you arrive.
- We have three minutes,
so I'm gonna take,
try to get to two questions,
something that you really
wanna ask of this panel.
Yep, right back there.
Yes, you.
- [Woman] Which one?
- So my name is Sarah
Fox, I'm class of '73.
We certainly were at Yale
during what you could call
a hyper politicized time.
But one of the things
that's been striking to me
as we've walked around the
campus is how tranquil it is,
how quiet it is?
You don't see political posters,
you don't see anything
about political events.
There was as millions of
people around the world
were demonstrating on
climate change yesterday,
there was a little, if
there were 35 people
out in front of Stirling
library during a little rally.
(background noise drowns other sounds)
They were out on the green
and that's where Yale students were.
So anyway, so that's my question I guess.
Just what is the sense now
about sort of political activism at Yale?
Has that changed about women,
particularly at a time now
where certain aspects of women's rights
seem to be very much under threat,
what is your sense of how the student body
feels about itself as
engaged in the world?
- I think we have a highly
engaged student body
across the board in a lot of ways.
The reason why you don't see posters
is because everything's
on the internet right now.
So they just, they do Facebook,
they connect with each other
that way, it's less posters.
But this is, you know
certainly if you've been here,
first of all there's sleeping,
that's why you don't
really see the right now.
But for the last couple of years,
certainly they have been
very much in the mix,
many of them are spending a lot of time
off-campus in campaigns,
they're doing work,
you know in legal organizations.
But we have a very politically savvy
socially responsible group of students
who represent a broad range of views.
So don't let the tranquility
which actually by the
way I enjoy right now
as a Dean of Students,
don't let that fool you
because they're very
much active, very active.
And I think you would be proud
that they are still
carrying on the tradition
of being of service in a variety of ways,
in a variety of countries
actually I would say.
So they are definitely.
Would you agree?
Yeah.
- As a former college president,
the only thing I would
say is it was always great
when our students were focusing
their political activities
against the national
issues outside the college
and not necessarily
against the administration.
(audience laughing)
- Exactly.
- There's someone over
here who's been trying,
yeah, right here.
- This one.
- Right in front, yes, no I--
- Okay, thank you.
I'm Ruth Gemmell, more '71.
I'm just curious about
the question of leadership
and what happens to people
after they leave here
and how you define that these days
particularly with the
emphasis on pre-professional
partly because of the cost
of living, cost of college,
a lot of more students
are on financial aid.
So like everybody does what they do here
and then they go work for
whoever can pay them the most.
So I just, since we talk about leadership,
how do you define it now?
- So we track what students are doing
after graduation very carefully,
we have good statistics
starting from the class of 2013
and so for that class we even
have data from five years out.
You know, basically, I
think we can be very proud
of our young alumni that they, you know,
that they engage very broadly
including in many areas
of public service at nonprofits.
To further encourage
that, president Salovey
approved this new program
called Domestic Summer Awards
which will pay students on financial aid
to work for a nonprofit
organization over the summers
so that these financial
concerns would not constrain
the types of education and experiences
that they would pursue
while they're here at Yale.
And we're seeing the impact, you know,
I think we're gonna see the
impact of that continuing
even after graduation.
And also just one other
additional statistic
about our students is
that a lot of them go work
but by five years out from
graduation over half of them
come do some form of graduate
or professional school education.
So I think that's a pretty
cool statistics as well.
- And Yale's financial aid
policies are incredibly generous
and so students are able to
graduate without loan burdens.
So those do not constrain decisions
about what they can do afterwards.
(audience applauding)
- So very quickly, do
you think the definition
of leadership has changed with women
being so much a part of Yale
or is it the measures are still the same
and women or meeting or
exceeding those measures.
- You know I ask this question,
I'm like 'cause I love
students working in my office
about what constitute
leadership at Yale College.
And what they said is, you
know, we typically think
of leadership positions on
campus as being the head
of the YDN, YCC, those organizations.
And most recently, the most recent woman
who was head of the YCC
was actually just last year
and I think they've been a 10 year hiatus
since the last woman who was a head of it.
But most of the students would say,
that yes those organizations are wonderful
but what they see as
leadership now are leadership
in the 600 organizations that we now have,
leadership on issues of social justice
and a lot of the things that
are really moving the campus
in ways that sometimes
are uncomfortable for us
are really being led by women,
and honestly women of color
are really stepping into the place,
talk about intersectionality.
So I think for this generation,
the concept of leader is broader
than we would typically say
and that most students see
themselves as being leaders
in some way shape or form
mostly because they all wanna
make some kind of an impact.
And what I think the shift has been
is actually they wanna
make an impact at home.
So many more of them are going back home
to make an impact that's
probably this shift
and that's where they see their leadership
as having (mumbles).
- You know this leadership has a long
and strange history if you think about it,
but everyone smirks if
you say 1,000 were leaders
but everyone knows a school like Yale
doesn't just accept some students
and say tries to develop
the talent of students
who are gonna have
disproportionate impact.
But also these students
have lived with pressure.
To apply to a college nowadays,
you have to have been the president
of at least three clubs in high school.
Let's just say, you've been
pushed into a certain definition
of what leadership is which
means I have the foremost role,
I have a certain prestige
or something of that sort.
I think by the time people
get out and in life,
they understand that's not
really what leadership was about,
it wasn't about the position you held,
it's about thinking about
how people take their gifts
and go have a disproportional impact,
how they make other people smarter,
how they ask more interesting questions,
how they make people think
that impossible ideas
might be less impossible than they appear.
And you know if I look in this room
and see people who I can see
with careers in medicine,
with careers in architecture,
with careers in academics,
the world needs all of those people,
it doesn't need everyone to be
the president of those things
but it needs people to be
the leader in more or less
the sense I have described.
- I think students would agree,
I think they say leadership is service.
(all applauding).
- That's a great note to end on.
Thank you everyone for being here
and thank you panelist.
(audience applauding)
(background noise drowns other sound)